ああああ
ああ
銭本計37歳
長崎県対馬で漁師をしています
今日は僕のちょっと変わったキャリアに
ついて紹介します
僕は大阪で生まれ兵庫県の明石市で育ち
ました
徒歩1分で海という環境で
父親の影響で釣りが大好きになりました
もっと海のこと魚のことを勉強したいと
いう思いで長崎大学水産学部に進学し大学
院を出て海の研究者の道を目指すように
なりました
海の中の魚がどのような要因で増えたり
減ったりするのかを調べることが僕の研究
テーマでした
研究の結果
魚は自然に増えたり減ったりするけれど
ここ数十年の間
魚が減少し続けている要因としては人間
活動
特に取りすぎの影響は決して小さくない
だろうという考えに至りました
これからもおいしい魚を食べ続けるために
今は取る量を控えながら
資源が回復するのを待たなければいけない
のではないか
どうすれば日本の漁業はよくな良くなるの
だろうか
そのようなことを考えていました
一方で
正直に言うと
研究者として最後の約2年ほどは
僕自身は研究者としてやっていく未来を
描けなくなっていました
先輩の研究者を見ていると書類作成や
会議などにとても忙しく
純粋に研究を行う時間は本当に少ないよう
に感じられました
それでも彼らはその少ない研究時間の中で
しっかりと業績をあげていました
とてもじゃないけれど僕にこのようなこと
をし続けることはできないんじゃないか
そう思いました
またそれまで順調にキャリアを歩めて
しまっていたのでこのまま周囲の期待に
応えないとと必要以上に思ったり
研究者として優秀に見られるためにはどう
したらいいかというようなことに神経を
すり減らしていたように思います
一度研究を離れないと自分らしさを見失っ
てしまう
直感的にそう感じていました
もっと自分らしいアプローチで
水産に関われる仕事があるんじゃない
だろうか
色々と考えていたときふと
御両親になってみてもいいんじゃないか
小さくてもいいので自分で取りすぎない
いう業を実践してみたい
そういう考えが次第に強くなってきました
既存の水産流通では魚の平均単価は低く
価格変動が大きいですが
自分で売り先を探して直接販売すれば安定
して高く売れるはず
高く売ることが出来れば必要以上に
たくさんの魚を取らなくてもいいんじゃ
ないか
販売先を探すところについては研究者時代
に鍛えたコミュニケーションや
わかりやすく伝えるスキルが役に立つはず
いろいろなアイディアが湧いてきました
そのようなアイデア出しと並行して漁業
現場を視察してまいりました
その中でここ対馬の豊かな海とそこで一生
懸命働く漁師たちに出会いここで仕事をし
たいそう思うようになりました
一人で歩んで行くのも怖かったので同じ
ような問題意識を持った研究者時代の友人
に声をかけて2人でフラッタワーという
小さな会社を立ち上げました
船は地元の漁師が使っていなかったものを
譲っていただきましたが
魚を捕るスキルもお客さんに魚を送る
ノウハウもゼロからのスタートで最初は
苦労しました
それでも魚を捕るスキルは周囲の漁師から
ならいい
良い状態で魚を送るノウハウはつながった
飲食店さんと二人三脚で向上させていき
ました
起業して4年ぐらいでようやく授業の方の
ようなものができてきて
社員やパートさんも入ってくれて少しずつ
大きくなっています
ラったわーのミッションは持続可能な水産
業を実現するということです
このミッションに対して今自分たちの行っ
ている取り組みはインパクトに欠けるもの
かもしれません
それでも自社らしさを失わずに経済を伴っ
ている今の会社の授業を僕は気に入ってい
ます
このような活動をしていると様々な方が
視察や仕事体験に来てくださいます
漁師という職業を将来の選択肢に入れて
いる人を
生産現場を見てみたいという料理人の方々
販売方法を勉強したいという他の地域の
漁師
デジタルの力で乳業を良くしたいと考えて
くれるスタートアップの方々
対馬をフィールドに研究をする研究者など
です
今の授業をしっかりと回しながら
弊社を訪れてくれる多種多様な方々を
巻き込みながら
水産業をより良くする次の一定を考えて
いきたいと思っています